we all grow up fantasizing about finding
true love with a knight in shining armor
and living happily ever after but that's
all it is fantasy are you okay
fear not I've been thrown much further
by much faster horses than your steel
steed not a scratch on that apparently
he believes that he's a 14th century
Knight so called Christopher Frederick
Lyons of March at your service oh boy
this is all my fault
where are they paying that lyrical
medley on the radio I'm going to help
until his memory comes back
what if he's dangerous trust me he's
harmless
first thing I think we should do is a
big reward row by at least a few
centuries greetings greetings I'll let
you get dressed you know time travel
isn't a real thing
right I have traveled here and it
matters not if I understand how
and I just want a valor and virtue will
give aid to those who seek but I fear I
must have turned him do you really think
going along with his little delusion is
helping a situation who are we to tell
him he's not who he says he is you sure
you want to wait what if Kol really is
who he says he is what if there are
things beyond our comprehension then I
would say you both need to get your
heads examined you don't have to go I
have no choice
[Music]
wherever you are stand any place I want
to be but no one can control their own
destiny nice catch
steady now milady
[Music]
you
you